he was one of the greatest aviators of
his generation
u.s pilot chuck yeager started off as an
aircraft mechanic before becoming a
world war
ii fighter ace and the first person to
break the sound barrier
charles yeager climbs down into the
cockpit of the rocket craft
it was on october 1947 and at the age of
24 that he flew an airplane through the
sound barrier at a speed of more than a
thousand kilometers an hour
such attempts had killed other pilots
before
he would later say he could have gone
even faster had the plane carried more
fuel
but he did continue to fly faster on
other dangerous missions
his tests were used by the u.s air force
and nasa to advance
research into flight and the u.s space
program
before his success he was already well
known in aviation
he shot down 13 german planes during
world war ii
five on a single mission he commanded
fighter squadrons
and flew 127 combat missions during the
vietnam war
during the 1960s he trained air force
personnel to become astronauts
26 people he tutored later went into
orbit under nasa
his image as an aviation legend gained
greater status in tom wolf's
best-selling book and later film
the right stuff sounds dangerous it's
very dangerous
he later said one of his regrets was not
going to college
as not having a degree prevented him
from becoming an astronaut
he never regarded himself as courageous
or a hero
often saying he was just doing his job a
job that experts say
led to new heights in aviation and space
exploration